there's been a lot of hype about the
possibility of violent protests at this
year's RNC but it's hard to imagine
anything too crazy going on with
literally thousands of cops here from
around the country some equipped for
what looks like war with the recent
shootings of police officers fear is
causing a lot of people to justify this
militarization but is this the sign of
suppression to come in just a few
protests here this week like this one
they've all been peaceful and heavily
please some say to police in fact a two
major protests here this week we found
herself surrounded by police
our producer Hadley was even stuck
inside a circle of cops as they removed
demonstrators from a public square
without any visible reason Cleveland
spent nearly 15 million dollars in
security precautions before the RNC
purchasing riot gear steel batons
tactical armor and handcuffs
president Obama has banned the sale of
some military equipment to law
enforcement but the money for Cleveland
was authorized through a federal grant
because the Department of Homeland
Security deemed the RNC a national
special security event now activists are
worried about what'll happen to the new
weapons after the Republicans leave the
weapons and the surveillance tools that
are frequently obtained with these
federal security grants our items that
then will stick around after the RNC and
these tools are being obtained without
the appropriate consultation process
that is required under the consent
decree and to make matters worse the
Cleveland Police Department doesn't
exactly have a shining record of
protecting the community it made
international headlines when officers
shot and killed 12 year-old Tamir rice
in 2014 and the department is still
under federal oversight for misconduct
for the RNC the police department put
600 of its officers on convention duty
and an additional 3,500 officers are on
loan and that means no public gatherings
are escaping the watchful eye of cops
everybody wants to stay safe but where
do we draw the line